and it's the same with male feminists as
well I mean male feminists they're doing
what they can to compete in the
masculine hierarchy have you ever heard
of the term sneaky syndrome
yeah that's basically what male
feminists are they're sneaky
yeah yeah exactly so just for those of
you who are listening it's a Zoological
Zoological it's a zoology term whereby
there's a certain few animals where the
alpha males will obviously dominate the
the herd or the Haram or whatever
and then the beta males will come in and
they'll disguise themselves as women
so that they can get past the alpha
males and then go and try and breed with
the ladies so I think we see that I
think Gad said talks about this have you
have you read much of GAD sad's work
um parasitic mind or parasitic mine's
the last one that I you know listen to
but I mean if you watch any any kind of
nature show you know I was watching one
the other day on Netflix called
Predators
um and you see that behavior you know
with the um with certain uh Prides of
lions too right
um happens in the primate you know
communities as well so I mean it's no
surprise that you get these male
feminists that are essentially your
sneaky of the animal kingdom
yeah yeah it's a thing and um another
thing when it comes to mass I mean how
old are you now Rich if you don't mind
me asking
I was born in the 70s I never give my
exact age out because there's too many
weirdos out there yeah no fair enough so
I mean you are in good shape you just
had a boxing fight you're still cruising
around you're still mentally switched on
uh and I think a lot of this has to do
with what you do with your endocrine
system and I find it really interesting
and when I'm a little bit older I think
I'll definitely definitely be doing this
when my testosterone levels start to
drop as well so
um for anybody who's listening out there
who might feel like their energy is
dropping or their testosterone's
dropping and they want to address it and
address the endocrine system what would
be your advice
so there's a chapter in my book on this
and in the updated second edition is
going to have given more information
which will be out soon but essentially
my recommendation is to track your blood
Labs on an annual basis from about the
age of 25 up I mean 30 should be the
latest I I think anyway because it's
usually by the age of 30 that
testosterone levels start to drop in men
and it's gradual it's not immediate like
when women hit menopause they hit this
wall their hormone panel changes
completely they stop dropping eggs they
basically age very rapidly you know from
that point onward uh collagen and their
skin you know diminishes drastically so
um for men it's not as obvious as that
right it's you know it's a slow
Progressive drop in your testosterone
levels like one to three percent per
year so if you're tracking it then you
should have some awareness after four or
five years of tracking this that okay
well it looks like my testosterone
levels are dropping
um you can try to optimize it naturally
there's lots of advice that I have in my
videos and even in my book that I talk
about there if that doesn't work then
you can optimize it with testosterone
therapy there's doctors that prescribe
um testosterone you can inject that
there's pellet formats there's lozengers
there's all kinds of ways that you can
administer it
um it's very safe it's very effective
it's efficient
um
Andrew huberman who's a podcaster he's a
he's basically a scientist that you know
talks a lot about uh things like sleep
and eyesight and all kinds of different
things uh um and he's done many podcasts
on testosterone and I think he said it
best when he said that testosterone
makes effort feel good so if you've got
healthy levels of optimized testosterone
in your body effort feels good doing
things feel good competing feels good
um it feels very natural and you know
when you get your levels optimized your
life is just better you know you perform
better you sleep better you bang better
you're stronger you're more competent
you're more aggressive
um I found anyway you know with me that
that when I got my levels optimized and
I got them to levels that that really
work for me it actually calmed me and it
focused me more
um you know there's a lot of a lot of
misinformation out there like they say
oh it's a testosterone will make you
make your balls uh shrink you'll go
blind you'll go bald you'll blah blah
blah and all these things and it's like
look man or you got prostate cancer or
you'll have heart attacks or whatever
and I've looked into all of those things
and they're not true uh testosterone
improves heart health it doesn't do
anything to affect prostate cancer if
you're going bald it's genetic it's got
nothing to do with testosterone levels
there's loads of bodybuilders out there
that have levels a hundred times higher
than me that have a better head of hair
because it's genetic right and so it's
like there's a lot of misinformation out
there and there's also a lot of pointing
and sputtering from uh you know wolf
culture basically telling men to be
softer because if you have high
testosterone you're toxically masculine
right so you get these dorks and these
nerds that of course are like oh you're
just a steroid header or juice head or
something like that it's like
say whatever you want man but I wouldn't
trade my life for yours so have fun
being poor dumb and a loser not having
no involved women in your life you know
sort of things so it's like you know you
always have to consider the source when
you get the criticism because hate only
ever comes from beneath you
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out